national oyster day is thursday and
we're going to show you how to celebrate
with freshly shucked oysters let's
welcome chef darren walters from
big sur oyster bar at the south point
welcome sir welcome you got me
you got me gloves i got you good ready
to go my first question before we start
shucking what's the main difference
between east coast and west coast
oysters oh the flavor mainly the flavor
you get some
sweeter flavor you get some bitter
flavors they get some saltiness
so mainly the flavor of the oyster the
taste
taste okay techniques to shucking how do
we do it what's the first thing i got
my glove on i want to keep that safe i
brought some shocking knives for you
so what do you want to do with the
oyster you want to take the oyster and
you want to
keep it safely in your hand you can use
it flat
or you can do do uh
um grip it hard grip it hard okay
i lost my trigger okay okay so you've
got your noise denied does it matter
which knife i use don't mind i wouldn't
use this this is better because this
will protect your hand okay
okay should i have the glove on this
hand you should but okay
that's right it's okay you're the master
i'll follow the teacher go ahead you
know left or right-handed
it's stuck on it carry on so then you
want to take the oyster knife
put it into the gap and then you just
pop it
i'm a feeling mine were pretty shocked
but that's okay you're looking at me
because i popped it in there
pop it pop it open yeah there you go
it's it's right there it's that easy
you made it look way too easy i think
there was some tv magic on this one give
me
give me one that's on that's on tv magic
okay there you go right there
we'll take the band off these are these
are gold seal now when you buy oysters
at the store and you get them you keep
them in the freezer in the fridge before
you have them
these are fresh so you keep these in the
fridge give them in the fridge right so
what you want to do with these you want
to get right into it
right in there yeah and that and then
you want to
pop it pop you hear it just let it pop
oh that's juicy there you go nice juicy
oyster right there now when you pop one
of these things open have you ever found
a pearl
not yet not yet i'm not i'm not that
lucky i've not been that lucky
so now uh what are these are these east
coast west coast these are these are
these are goats
gold seal gold bands that's why they've
got the gold band around them
these are pressurized so they're
pressurized and they come from louisiana
so they're really safe to eat because
they're pressurized they pressurize them
so they pop really open
easy and they kill all the bacteria from
what's ever in the seas now you have
some great deals going on and also as
you tell me about your deals tell me the
different styles of oysters we have in
front of us well we have the west coast
oysters which are
like the blue point and the uh east
coast
east coast the blue points west coast of
kamamuto
we have the uh ones from the gulf which
are the gold band which i've explained
look how big these are these are some
juicy ones right here these are some
these are some big oysters
uh we also have a little bit of uh you
know you can take a little oyster
mm-hmm we're gonna do a shooter we do a
shooter okay we've got the
little oysters
oysters everything like that
i did that thing whole las vegas now
we'll be right back thank you chef
you're welcome anytime